just see if Damen can uh can hear us
Courtside Dame Ernie Johnson in Atlanta
we sounding okay to you yep I can hear
you very good let's see if you can
multitask here cuz uh that that looked
like it might be tough to do but um hey
here's the deal it seems to me just from
the outside looking in uh like you like
this tournament is kind of grown on you
guys and from the very start of it to
Now you kind of have a better
understanding of it and what it going to
mean if you can stay alive in it true
yeah I think it's getting it's growing
on everybody a little bit more um in the
beginning we didn't really know what it
was we just knew money was on the line
uh and then you start to learn more over
the course of time and I think everybody
just wanted it more and more and now
it's it's turned into you know Real
Entertainment real competitive
basketball man we playing for
something Dame sh here we all know
you're a true unselfish player uh when
you first got to Milwaukee did you find
yourself looking for yian a little bit
too much you talking about on the court
yeah yeah I think it was uh you know one
of those things where you playing with
another star and you don't want to step
on his toes too much uh coming into his
situation uh you know and just trying to
find that middle ground and being myself
and doing what they brought me here to
do and that that takes time you know
what I'm saying but once I I kind of got
in a better Groove and got in a better
flow it started to happen naturally but
I think that's normal though so I
definitely I definitely in the beginning
uh but I'm slowly starting to get more
and more comfortable D when you're a
great player you can get your shot
anytime you want it how has the
adjustment like you know what I got to
get this ball to Middleton I got to get
this to Lopez I got to get it to Porter
how have you made that
transition uh I think that that's
probably been the easiest part uh I
think when you are the the guy on the
team and you have all this
responsibility you go home some nights
and you complain about man you know I
need this I need that and I need you
know I want to have a guy like this or a
guy like that and then when you get in a
situation where you know you probably
not going to have to score 30 every
night or you probably not going to
always have a ball um it can be a little
bit weird so you know when I find myself
in that situation you know I just
embrace it so far this season that's
that's kind of been my mentality is to
embrace it and uh you know it's it's not
going to be about what I've done my my
whole career is going to be about you
know how I got to play here for us to
win and that's going to take some
sacrifice and some understanding of what
the situation is and that's that's been
my mentality uh you know course of the
season so far you know Dame you you've
made the trans you've been in Portland
so long and now you made the transition
what's the biggest surprise about being
in Milwaukee the Mean Streets of Ernie
Johnson's
Hometown man I uh I I don't know what
I'll say the biggest surprise is but I
would say
uh just the just being a part of a a a
winning culture you know when everything
is not perfect you know obviously we won
a lot of games in Portland and you know
it's a great organization we had a lot
of great years but you know it's a lot
of things that we're in the process of
right now trying to learn each other
learning a new coach trying to figure
things out you know it hasn't been
perfect but we've been able to win a lot
of games through that so uh I would say
that just that speaks to like the
winning culture here it's just being
able to to learn things on the Fly and
put it all together but still be able to
win these games are you a big fan of BR
worst yet dve a big fan of who BR
worst I can't hear you the food okay he
doesn't know what bror is you said you
said bror like
the uh I wouldn't say a big fan
but I have one I gota hey appreciate the
time man good luck tonight always good
talking to you Dave appreciate it
appreciate
it we what's the name of the Soul Food
place I took y'all when we I like uh uh
bror who Joe wolf you taught me about
curl cheese too that thing is
awesome